teachers in the clark county district
say they don't have access to adequate
health insurance they're reporting
accounts being sent to collections and
then doctors dropping coverage all due
to tht health not paying its bills kate
houston live outside of ccsd school
board meeting where teachers are making
their voices heard on this important
issue kate
yes well after 45 minutes of public
comment they are now moving to some
other agenda items the teachers union is
making a presentation tonight on tht
health and teachers tell me that the
issues with the company is causing
unnecessary stress and mismanagement is
now impacting their credit scores this
is not a teacher's problem this is a
community problem teacher nicole whaley
says she has months of unpaid claims
she'll be speaking at tonight's board
meeting asking for the district the
teachers union and thd health to take
responsibility for what's happening we
need information like i can be patient
that there is
a problem and that we're fixing it but
there needs to be transparency there
needs to be a plan that needs to be an
answer according to the union thd health
is in a nearly 43 million dollar deficit
this financial year in may ccsd provided
an advance of 35 million dollars thd
health also hired new management but
whaley says a lot of damage has already
been done impacting teachers credit
scores and buying power to tell me oh
you have to let
our financial responsibility fall on you
and your purchasing power and your
credit score
is absurd to me and i just don't like
how much more um of the accountability
do teachers have to take before other
people acknowledge that it's not us
we'll back out live a class action
lawsuit was filed in august against tht
health allied collection services and
digestive disease center reporting live
from
flamingo and eastern kate houston live
local now